[Music]
the first trailer for The Joker movie
has just dropped and fans of the DC
super film are in for a real treat after
the studio dropped the ball with the
Jared Leo portrayal in Suicide Squad it
appears that the character is being done
justice again the trailer has a hell of
a lot to unpack from it and throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the movie this is full spoilers ahead so
if you want to go into the film as blind
as possible then I highly recommend that
you turn off now with that out the way
let's put a smile on their face and get
into my trailer breakdown of Joker okay
so the first thing that you need to know
is that Joker will be released on
October 4th later this year the film
feels like it was ripped straight out of
a Scorsese masterpiece and there are
clear similarities to the seminal movie
taxi driver by the director this comes
in the form of the setting clothing
choice and general atmosphere it's clear
that the studio are trying to make this
a serious and earnest as possible with
the film feeling more like a crime drama
than a comic book movie obviously films
like Logan have shown this as possible
and though the movie has some big shoes
to fill I actually think that it can
pull it off
this is purely down to Phoenix's
performance which seems like a real
course-correction for the character also
there have been differing reports about
the movies age rating and it looks like
this is definitely going to be aiming
towards an R in the US and 15 in the UK
the trailer itself opens with Arthur
Fleck who seems to be running pretty low
on his luck
black stumbles through the streets of
Gotham and we hear the words my mother
always tells me to smile and put on a
happy face she told me I had a purpose
to bring laughter and joy to the world
at this point we see him in clown attire
before he's beaten up by thugs of Gotham
who steal his sign integrated between us
his images of him dancing with his
mother in a diner before you see his
spiral into Gotham's most dangerous and
psychotic criminal there are also shots
where he sits inside a comedy club which
is when he begins laughing which is
terrifying and then star
carry out his crimes in a clown mask
it's clear that there's a big effect on
the city and his actions are really game
changes for the city with policemen
asking what kind of coward would do
something that cold-blooded before
another cop states someone who hides
behind a mask this is obviously a
comment on the subversion to the city
that Batman adds by using a mask apply
other masks criminals we then hear the
words I used to think my life was a
tragedy but now I realize it's a comedy
it's clear that the character is
frequenting Arkham Asylum for some
reason and this could be because his
mother is a patient there or because
he's having to attend it himself either
way he's going through a massive
psychotic breakdown and I can't wait to
see the terror that he unleashes on
Gotham
overall it's clear that this is going to
be an amazing role for Phoenix who is
really living the character I can't wait
to see the movie when it releases in
October and this could be another huge
win for the DC Universe whilst there are
no direct adaptations to this story from
the comics as Joker's origin is seldom
touch upon there are clear allusions to
The Killing Joke
and those who haven't read that book
should definitely pick it up if this has
piqued their interest obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on the trailer and
if I miss anything be sure to let me
know in the comments below you enjoyed
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my full breakdown of
yesterday's new Avenger trailer which
would be linked at the end this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
you
[Music]